Our episodes deal with serious and often distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local Crisis Centre. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support, please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website. Oregon City Attorney James O'Leary was in his office on Tuesday, July 27, 1976, when a man and woman entered wishing to speak to him. Deseveled and exhausted, they had just emerged from the Mount Hood National Forest after a weekend spent camping and fishing in the wilderness.
我们的节目涉及严肃且往往令人痛苦的事件。如果您在任何时候感到需要支持，请联系您当地的危机中心。如需获取保密支持的电话号码，请查看您手机应用或我们网站上的本期节目说明。1976年7月27日星期二，俄勒冈市律师詹姆斯·奥利里（James O'Leary）正在办公室里，这时一男一女走了进来，希望能与他交谈。他们衣衫不整、疲惫不堪，刚刚从胡德山国家森林（Mount Hood National Forest）出来，此前他们在荒野中露营和钓鱼度过了一个周末。
They planned to speak to the police regarding a tragedy that had happened there, but were apprehensive about doing so without seeking legal advice first. After hearing their incredible story, James O'Leary escorted the distraught pair to the county sheriff's office. When detectives asked why they hadn't come forward sooner, the man remarked, I have a criminal record and I didn't want to face authorities. I was afraid they wouldn't believe me. It was getting late on Friday, July 23, 1976.
他们计划向警方报告在那里发生的一起悲剧，但担心在没有先寻求法律建议的情况下这样做。在听完他们令人难以置信的故事后，詹姆斯·奥利里护送这对心烦意乱的男女前往县治安官办公室。当侦探询问他们为什么不早点站出来时，那名男子说：“我有犯罪记录，我不想面对当局。我担心他们不会相信我。”那是1976年7月23日星期五，天色已晚。
29-year-old Tom Brown was driving his old red GMC pickup truck deep into the Mount Hood National Forest. By the time he reached the North Fork Dam on the Clackamas River, daylight was fading and there were very few people around. Tom brought his car to a stop near a boat launch area and left his engine running as he hurried over to a nearby fish ladder. The long and narrow canal-like structure ran parallel to the river and was built to help fish migrate easily upstream.
29岁的汤姆·布朗（Tom Brown）开着他那辆旧红色GMC皮卡车，深入胡德山国家森林。当他到达克拉克马斯河（Clackamas River）上的北岔大坝（North Fork Dam）时，天色渐暗，周围几乎没有人。汤姆在船只下水区附近停下车，让引擎保持运转，然后匆忙赶往附近的鱼梯。那条长而狭窄、类似运河的结构与河流平行，旨在帮助鱼类轻松向上游洄游。
Tom was standing alone observing the water when a young man approached and started talking to him. His name was Julio Torres and he was camping in the forest with his wife for their one-year wedding anniversary. An avid fisherman, Julio had been struggling to catch anything in the area and was seeking any possible advice from Tom. Tom was less than enthused by the interruption and made this clear by averting his gaze and giving curt responses.
汤姆独自站在那里观察水面时，一名年轻男子走过来开始与他交谈。他的名字叫胡里奥·托雷斯（Julio Torres），他正和妻子在森林里露营，庆祝他们结婚一周年。作为一名狂热的垂钓者，胡里奥在这一带一直没能钓到什么东西，于是向汤姆寻求任何可能的建议。汤姆对这次打扰并不热心，他通过避开目光和简短的回答表达了这一点。
Julio persisted. All we found were a couple of suckers, he told the disinterested Tom. Minutes later, Julio's teen-aged wife, Candra, appeared and joined in the conversation. Her presence loosened up the standoffish Tom, who managed to crack a smile. Turning back to Julio, he finally offered some insider information to help the struggling couple. Earlier that day, he'd been doing some logging work in the forest when he saw a truckload of fish being offloaded into the river nearby.
胡里奥坚持不懈。“我们只发现了几条吸口鱼，”他告诉冷淡的汤姆。几分钟后，胡里奥十几岁的妻子坎德拉（Candra）出现并加入了谈话。她的出现让冷漠的汤姆放松了下来，他勉强挤出了一丝微笑。转过身对胡里奥说，他终于提供了一些内部消息来帮助这对苦苦挣扎的夫妇。那天早些时候，他在森林里做伐木工作时，看到一卡车的鱼被卸载到附近的河里。
Other fisherman Julio had spoken to throughout the day had also mentioned a fish dump and Julio was intrigued. That's where I'm headed, Tom told him. Julio was keen to go there as well, but had driven his sedan down to just half a tank of gas, travelling further into the forest it didn't seem wise. Tom reassured him. The fishing spot wasn't too far away and half a tank should get them there. If Julio and Candra wound up stranded, Tom was willing to drop off some gas in the morning
胡里奥整天交谈过的其他渔民也提到过鱼类倾倒点，胡里奥很感兴趣。“我就要去那里，”汤姆告诉他。胡里奥也想去那里，但他开的轿车油箱只剩下一半油了，再往森林深处开似乎不太明智。汤姆让他放心。钓鱼点离这里不远，半箱油应该足够他们到达那里。如果胡里奥和坎德拉被困住，汤姆愿意在早上送些汽油过去，
to get them moving again. The trio headed back to their respective cars. Tom drove off in the direction of the fishing spot and Julio, having weighed up the risks, followed behind. When Tom pulled over for a brief stop, so too did Julio. The sedan's emptying fuel tank remained a concern, so Tom offered to drive Julio and Candra in his truck the remainder of the way to preserve what little gas they had. The couple declined the offer as they had been using their car to sleep in.
让他们重新上路。三人回到各自的车上。汤姆朝着钓鱼点的方向开车离去，胡里奥权衡了风险后，紧随其后。当汤姆靠边短暂停车时，胡里奥也停了下来。轿车油箱见底仍然是个问题，所以汤姆主动提出用他的卡车搭载胡里奥和坎德拉走完剩下的路，以节省他们仅剩的汽油。这对夫妇拒绝了提议，因为他们一直把车当作睡觉的地方。
Where is this spot, Julio asked. Just beyond Bagby Hot Springs Road, Tom explained, before returning to his truck and continuing onwards. The sedan tailed him once more. By now, the road was curving deeper into more isolated areas of the forest. Once on Bagby Hot Springs Road, the two car convoy passed another vehicle travelling in the opposite direction with a father and daughter inside. They encountered no one else.
“那个点在哪里？”胡里奥问。汤姆解释说：“就在巴格比温泉路（Bagby Hot Springs Road）后面，”然后回到他的卡车继续前进。轿车再次尾随他。此时，道路正蜿蜒深入森林中更偏僻的地区。一旦进入巴格比温泉路，两辆车的车队就与另一辆载着一对父女、正朝相反方向行驶的车辆擦肩而过。他们没有再遇到其他人。
Tom turned down an unpaved bumpy logging road that snaked through the looming pine and fir trees. The sedan followed suit. By now, the sun had almost set and Tom pulled over to set up camp for the night. Julio and Candra joined him. The couple were also travelling with their pet dog, a collie named Rusty, and as the sky darkened, the group settled around a fire to eat their dinner. Tom drank some liquor which he offered Julio and Candra who each took a sip.
汤姆转入一条未铺设的颠簸伐木路，这条路蜿蜒穿过高耸的松树和冷杉树。轿车也紧随其后。此时，太阳几乎落山了，汤姆靠边停车准备露营过夜。胡里奥和坎德拉加入了他的行列。这对夫妇还带着他们的宠物狗，一只名叫拉斯蒂（Rusty）的牧羊犬。随着天色变暗，一行人围坐在火堆旁吃晚饭。汤姆喝了一些酒，并提议让胡里奥和坎德拉也喝点，两人各抿了一口。
After eating, Tom collected a rifle from his truck and set out to take a night walk in the surrounding woodland. Julio and Candra accompanied him on the short hike. Tom was familiar with the area and headed to a nearby meadow, explaining that he hunted deer there. As they approached the clearing, Tom offered the couple his binoculars so they could observe several deer foraging up ahead. A little further away from them, several bear cubs were playing.
吃完饭后，汤姆从卡车里拿出一支步枪，出发去周围的林地进行夜间散步。胡里奥和坎德拉陪他进行了短途徒步。汤姆对该地区很熟悉，他前往附近的一个草地，解释说他常在那里猎鹿。当他们接近空地时，汤姆把双筒望远镜递给这对夫妇，让他们观察前方觅食的几只鹿。在离他们稍远一点的地方，几只小熊正在玩耍。
Tom, Julio and Candra eventually returned to their camp where they slept in their vehicles. Tom woke first the following morning at roughly 5am. He wandered over to the sedan and banged on its hood to wake Julio and Candra. Then the trio decided to try catching a fish for breakfast. Tom drove the others to another area of the forest before leading them on foot along an overgrown trail that led to the riverbank. Once there, Julio and Candra perched themselves on a rock. Tom fished by himself a little further away.
汤姆、胡里奥和坎德拉最终回到营地，在各自的车里睡觉。第二天早上大约5点，汤姆先醒了。他走到轿车旁，敲打引擎盖叫醒胡里奥和坎德拉。随后，三人决定尝试钓一条鱼作为早餐。汤姆开车把其他人带到森林的另一个区域，然后带领他们沿着一条杂草丛生的小径步行前往河岸。到达那里后，胡里奥和坎德拉坐在岩石上。汤姆在稍远一点的地方独自钓鱼。
Time slipped by and nothing seemed to be biting. Eventually, the group gave up and returned to their campsite empty-handed. There, Tom and Julio came up with a new plan. They'd head back into the woods and try their luck at hunting some deer instead. Hunting was illegal in Oregon during the summer months, but that didn't dissuade them. Tom had two rifles on him, a Winchester lever action and a .22 caliber savage. He handed one to Julio and kept the other for himself. Three days later, Tom Brown arrived at the office of Oregon City Attorney James O'Leary
时间悄然流逝，似乎什么也没上钩。最终，一行人放弃了，空手回到营地。在那里，汤姆和胡里奥想出了一个新计划。他们决定回到树林里，碰碰运气去猎鹿。在俄勒冈州，夏季狩猎是非法的，但这并没有劝阻他们。汤姆身上有两支步枪，一支温彻斯特杠杆式步枪和一支.22口径萨维奇步枪。他把其中一支递给胡里奥，自己留下了另一支。三天后，汤姆·布朗抵达了俄勒冈市律师詹姆斯·奥利里的办公室，
where he announced that Julio Torres was dead. Tom explained that he and Julio had been hunting in the Mount Hood National Forest when a terrible accident took place. Julio was scoping out the area with a pair of binoculars when he spotted a deer. Tom handed Julio his rifle to free up his hands so he too could have a look through the binoculars. After observing the deer for himself, Tom decided he'd take a shot at it. He returned the binoculars to Julio, who in turn handed Tom back his rifle. As the Winchester was being passed between them, Tom grabbed the firearms balance point
他在那里宣布胡里奥·托雷斯已经死亡。汤姆解释说，他和胡里奥在胡德山国家森林狩猎时发生了一起可怕的事故。胡里奥正用双筒望远镜观察该地区，当时他发现了一只鹿。汤姆把步枪递给胡里奥，腾出双手，这样他也可以通过望远镜看一看。在自己观察完鹿之后，汤姆决定开枪射击。他把望远镜还给胡里奥，胡里奥随后把步枪还给汤姆。当温彻斯特步枪在他们之间传递时，汤姆抓住了枪的平衡点，
with one finger on the trigger. Although he didn't pull it, the rifle fired mid-exchange. The single bullet penetrated Julio's head, killing him instantly. Tom's shocking story was supported by the only other person with him that weekend, Candra Torres. She had escorted Tom to James O'Leary's office to ensure he wouldn't be charged for a crime he didn't commit. Between sobs, Candra revealed that she had witnessed the shooting with her own eyes as she was standing a couple of feet behind the two men when it happened.
一根手指扣在扳机上。虽然他没有扣动扳机，但步枪在交换过程中走火了。那颗子弹击穿了胡里奥的头部，当场死亡。汤姆令人震惊的故事得到了那个周末与他在一起的唯一另一个人——坎德拉·托雷斯的证实。她护送汤姆来到詹姆斯·奥利里的办公室，以确保他不会因未犯下的罪行而被起诉。坎德拉在啜泣中透露，她亲眼目睹了枪击事件，因为事发时她就站在两名男子身后几英尺处。
Her panicked screams had startled her pet dog Rusty, who turned aggressive. As Tom Brown rushed back to the campsite, Rusty ran at him growling. Certain the dog was about to attack, Tom scrambled his rifle into position and fired, killing the animal in self-defense. Later that day, Candra cried and nodded along as Tom repeated their story to detectives at the county sheriff's office. When asked why they hadn't come forward sooner, Tom admitted that he was initially reluctant to go to the police due to the previous run-ins he'd had with the law. Tom had a string of offensives listed against his name, most of which were petty and related to robbery.
她惊慌失措的尖叫声惊吓到了她的宠物狗拉斯蒂，它变得具有攻击性。当汤姆·布朗冲回营地时，拉斯蒂咆哮着向他冲来。确信狗要攻击自己，汤姆迅速将步枪架好并开枪，出于自卫杀死了这只动物。那天晚些时候，当汤姆在县治安官办公室向侦探重复他们的故事时，坎德拉哭着点头表示同意。当被问及为什么不早点站出来时，汤姆承认，由于之前与法律的冲突，他最初不愿去警察局。汤姆名下有一连串的犯罪记录，其中大部分是轻微的盗窃罪。
After accidentally killing Julio Torres, Tom sat in shock at the group's campsite, mulling over what to do next. He was convinced that with his criminal record, officers would try to charge him with murder. I finally knew I had to split, that no one would believe me, Tom told detectives. I told Candra she could do what she wanted, but that I was going to head to the mountains. She said I couldn't leave her there, that I had to take her back to civilization, but I said no way, I'm going. I told her she could go with me if she wanted, but she'd better hurry and get her stuff together. Unable to navigate out of the sprawling, unfamiliar and dangerous forest alone, Candra opted to stay with Tom, hoping he would come to his senses.
在意外杀死胡里奥·托雷斯后，汤姆坐在营地里感到震惊，思考着下一步该怎么办。他确信，凭借他的犯罪记录，警察会试图以谋杀罪起诉他。“我最终知道我必须离开，没有人会相信我，”汤姆告诉侦探。“我告诉坎德拉她可以做她想做的事，但我打算去山里。她说我不能把她留在那儿，我必须带她回到文明世界，但我说没门，我要走了。我告诉她如果她想的话可以跟我一起走，但她最好快点收拾好东西。”由于无法独自走出广阔、陌生且危险的森林，坎德拉选择留在汤姆身边，希望他能恢复理智。
Tom covered Julio and rushed his bodies with shrubbery to deter animals from scavenging their remains. Then, over the next three days, he trudged deeper and deeper into the forest with Candra in tow. They dressed under the stars in a sleeping bag and at a certain point, Tom tossed the rifle that had killed Julio into the surrounding brush, along with a bag of ammunition. Sensing Tom had since calmed down, Candra worked to convince him to return to town and tell police what had happened. Her persistence paid off, and Tom finally agreed. By then, the pair were well and truly lost. It took a while for Tom to find his way back to a familiar trail, but once he did, he managed to get them both back to the campsite.
汤姆用灌木丛覆盖了胡里奥的尸体，以防止动物啃食遗体。随后，在接下来的三天里，他带着坎德拉在森林里越走越深。他们在星空下睡在睡袋里，在某个时刻，汤姆把杀死胡里奥的步枪连同一袋弹药扔进了周围的灌木丛中。感觉到汤姆已经冷静下来，坎德拉努力说服他回到镇上告诉警察发生了什么事。她的坚持得到了回报，汤姆最终同意了。到那时，两人确实已经迷路了。汤姆花了一段时间才找到回熟悉小径的路，但一旦找到，他设法把他们俩都带回了营地。
He then drove Candra straight to Oregon City to see James O'Leary, an attorney who had represented Tom in his previous criminal matters. This was a precautionary measure to ensure Tom wouldn't be tricked into facing any murder charges. By the time they met with police, Tom and Candra were destroyed, but cooperative. They agreed to provide formal statements separately. This gave detectives the opportunity to check for inconsistencies in their story and determine if anything was afoot. But nothing raised their suspicions. The pair's account, even when told individually, was consistent and matching. While obviously upset, Candra was lucid and rational.
随后，他直接开车送坎德拉去俄勒冈市见詹姆斯·奥利里，这位律师曾代理过汤姆之前的刑事案件。这是一种预防措施，以确保汤姆不会被诱骗去面对任何谋杀指控。当他们见到警察时，汤姆和坎德拉已经崩溃，但非常配合。他们同意分别提供正式陈述。这让侦探们有机会检查他们故事中的不一致之处，并确定是否有猫腻。但没有任何事情引起他们的怀疑。这对夫妇的陈述，即使是单独讲述时，也是一致且吻合的。虽然显然很不安，但坎德拉头脑清醒且理智。
She was adamant that the shooting was not Tom's fault. She was also appreciative of Tom. Had he not helped her, she would still be lost in the immense forest, all alone. Later that night, Tom Brown escorted investigators into the Mount Hood National Forest. It was almost 8.30 when the group arrived at the location where Tom, Julio and Candra had set up camp. Sweeping the area with high-powered torches, investigators spotted the trio's burnt-out cooking fire and the Torres's sedan. 200 yards away, beneath the fronds of some ferns, was the body of Julio Torres. He lay face down about 30 feet off the road and down an embankment. There was blood on the ground higher up by the edge of the road,
她坚称枪击事件不是汤姆的错。她也很感激汤姆。如果不是他帮助她，她现在仍然会独自迷失在广阔的森林中。那天晚上晚些时候，汤姆·布朗护送调查人员进入胡德山国家森林。当一行人到达汤姆、胡里奥和坎德拉露营的地点时，时间已近8点30分。调查人员用强力手电筒扫视该地区，发现了三人烧毁的炊火和托雷斯夫妇的轿车。200码外，在一些蕨类植物的叶子下，是胡里奥·托雷斯的尸体。他脸朝下躺在离路约30英尺远的路堤下。路边更高的地方有血迹，
pinpointing the location where the shooting had taken place. Due to the hot summer weather, Julio's body was already in an advanced state of decomposition, but a gunshot wound was clearly visible in his head. Rusty had sustained a similar wound. His body was found further along the trail, also haphazardly covered with leaves. Tom had since willingly surrendered the 22-caliber sabbage rifle he had used to shoot Rusty. The following morning, he led investigators through a heavily wooded area to where he had discarded the Winchester rifle that killed Julio. They had to go on foot, trekking through thick vegetation as they followed the Colourwash River upstream.
标明了枪击发生的位置。由于炎热的夏季天气，胡里奥的尸体已经处于高度腐烂状态，但头部清晰可见枪伤。拉斯蒂也受了类似的伤。它的尸体在小径更远的地方被发现，同样被随意地用树叶覆盖着。汤姆此后自愿交出了他用来射杀拉斯蒂的.22口径萨维奇步枪。第二天早上，他带领调查人员穿过一片茂密的树林，来到他丢弃杀死胡里奥的温彻斯特步枪的地方。他们必须步行，穿过茂密的植被，沿着科拉瓦什河（Collawash River）向上游走。
They walked for hours through the forest across the river and then along another stream. The forest had become a dense, disorientating maze, but there was one clue that indicated they were heading in the right direction. Investigators noticed a set of Tom's footprints that had been previously crushed into the earth. A smaller pair, believed to be cantras, tailed them. As detailed in the book Empty Promises by True Crime Author Ian Rule, after 10 hours of hiking, Tom eventually stopped, pointed and remarked, There it is. There's my rifle. They had arrived at the site where he and Candra camped on their second night together in the wilderness.
他们在森林里穿过河流，然后沿着另一条溪流走了几个小时。森林变成了一个密集、令人迷失方向的迷宫，但有一个线索表明他们正朝着正确的方向前进。调查人员注意到了一组汤姆之前踩在泥土里的脚印。一双较小的脚印，被认为是坎德拉的，跟在后面。正如真实犯罪作家伊恩·鲁尔（Ian Rule）在《空洞的承诺》（Empty Promises）一书中所述，经过10小时的徒步旅行，汤姆最终停下来，指着并说：“就在那儿。那是我的步枪。”他们到达了他和坎德拉在荒野中共同度过的第二个夜晚露营的地点。
Although Tom said he'd thrown a plastic bag that contained about 11 bullets into the underbrush nearby, they were unable to find it. Detectives did recover a sleeping bag that almost looked like it had been shredded due to being dragged through the rough terrain. Tom said he and Candra had thrown it away once they found the trail home again. Over the coming days, Tom remained obliging and eager to assist with the investigation. He willingly provided a second statement and underwent a polygraph test which he passed. With everything aligning with Tom and Candra's version of events,
虽然汤姆说他把一个装有大约11颗子弹的塑料袋扔进了附近的灌木丛中，但他们没能找到。侦探们确实找回了一个睡袋，看起来像是被拖过崎岖地形而撕裂了。汤姆说，一旦他们找到回家的路，他和坎德拉就把它扔掉了。在接下来的几天里，汤姆一直很配合，并渴望协助调查。他自愿提供了第二份陈述，并接受了测谎仪测试，结果通过了。随着一切都与汤姆和坎德拉的事件版本相吻合，
Giulio Torres's death was ruled accidental. Lola Bates was deeply worried about her daughter, Candra. At just 16 years old, Candra was too young to suddenly find herself a widow. The weekend camping trip into the Mount Hood National Forest was supposed to be a celebration of Candra and Giulio's first wedding anniversary. Candra had been a young bride having married Giulio who was five years older than her when she was just 15. Candra's family was religious and her father had encouraged Candra and Giulio to marry before their relationship became too physical.
胡里奥·托雷斯的死亡被裁定为意外。萝拉·贝茨（Lola Bates）非常担心她的女儿坎德拉。年仅16岁的坎德拉太年轻了，无法突然发现自己成了寡妇。进入胡德山国家森林的周末露营之旅本应是庆祝坎德拉和胡里奥结婚一周年。坎德拉是一位年轻的新娘，她在15岁时就嫁给了比她大五岁的胡里奥。坎德拉的家庭很虔诚，她的父亲鼓励坎德拉和胡里奥在关系变得过于亲密之前结婚。
Wedding photos showed Candra in a long-sleeved lace dress. Her long dark red hair parted down the middle and hanging over her shoulders. In one picture, she fed cake to a beaming Giulio who was tall and broad-shouldered with thick dark hair, matching sideburns and a mustache. The Oregon-based couple lived in a small apartment in the small city of Campy with Rusty, their rough collie dog, who had been Candra's pet since childhood. Following Giulio and Rusty's sudden and violent deaths, Candra stayed with her parents so they could look after her. Lola watched her daughter closely in those first few days. She couldn't shake the feeling that something wasn't quite right.
婚礼照片显示坎德拉穿着一件长袖蕾丝礼服。她那头深红色的长发从中间分开，垂在肩上。在一张照片中，她给笑容满面的胡里奥喂蛋糕，胡里奥身材高大，肩膀宽阔，留着浓密的深色头发、相配的鬓角和胡须。这对居住在俄勒冈州的夫妇住在坎皮（Campy）小城的一间小公寓里，带着拉斯蒂，那是他们养的粗毛牧羊犬，也是坎德拉童年以来的宠物。在胡里奥和拉斯蒂突然且暴力的死亡后，坎德拉和父母住在一起，以便他们照顾她。萝拉在最初的几天里密切注视着女儿。她无法摆脱一种感觉，即有些事情不太对劲。
Candra's voice when describing the shootings didn't sound like her usual self. As Lola told the television program Forensic Files, it was as though Candra's words were coming out of a stereo, being replayed or something. Perhaps this was simply the way she was processing her grief, but it still gave Lola pause. It wasn't until Candra returned to the apartment she'd shared with Giulio that her demeanor changed. Her parents went with her, and as soon as Candra stepped through the door, she broke down in sobs. Candra suddenly began begging her parents, Mama and Daddy, don't hate me, don't hate me.
坎德拉在描述枪击事件时，声音听起来不像她平时那样。正如萝拉告诉电视节目《法医档案》（Forensic Files）的那样，就好像坎德拉的话是从立体声中传出来的，被重播了一样。也许这只是她处理悲伤的方式，但这仍然让萝拉感到迟疑。直到坎德拉回到她和胡里奥合住的公寓，她的举止才发生了变化。她的父母陪着她，坎德拉一进门就崩溃大哭。坎德拉突然开始恳求她的父母：“妈妈和爸爸，不要恨我，不要恨我。”
Ever since she'd returned home, Candra Torres had struggled to comprehend her thoughts and feelings. It was as though her mind was a blur, with many details missing. She remembered the lead-up to that fateful weekend. She and Giulio didn't have much money, but they still wanted to celebrate their first anniversary with the trip away somewhere. The obvious answer was to go camping. Candra suggested that they traveled to the coast where they had their honeymoon, but Giulio loved fishing and wanted to share the hobby with his wife, so he asked if they could instead head into the mountains.
自从回到家后，坎德拉·托雷斯就一直在努力理解自己的想法和感受。她的思绪仿佛一片模糊，丢失了许多细节。她记得那个决定性周末之前的准备工作。她和胡里奥没有多少钱，但他们仍然想去某个地方旅行来庆祝他们的第一个周年纪念日。显而易见的答案是去露营。坎德拉建议他们去他们度蜜月的地方——海边，但胡里奥喜欢钓鱼，想和妻子分享这个爱好，所以他问他们是否可以改去山里。
Candra agreed, telling herself they could always visit the beach another time. The night before they left for the Mount Hood National Forest, Candra's sleep was disrupted by a nightmare. She woke terrified, but was unable to remember the exact details of her dream. All she knew was that it had something to do with their impending trip. Candra told a friend about her bad dream the next morning of Thursday, July 22. They advised her to take a Bible with her for spiritual protection, and Candra tucked one away in amongst her clothes and other belongings. She also brought up her nightmare to Giulio, thinking he would settle her nerves.
坎德拉同意了，告诉自己他们总能找时间去海滩。在他们出发前往胡德山国家森林的前一天晚上，坎德拉的睡眠被一场噩梦打断了。她惊恐地醒来，但无法记起梦的具体细节。她只知道这与他们即将到来的旅行有关。第二天早上，即7月22日星期四，坎德拉告诉一位朋友她做的噩梦。他们建议她带一本圣经以寻求精神保护，坎德拉把它塞进了衣服和其他物品中。她还向胡里奥提到了她的噩梦，以为他会让她平静下来。
To Candra's surprise, Giulio admitted that he too felt inexplicably anxious about the trip. For peace of mind, they decided to invite one of Giulio's friends to camp with them, but he wasn't at home when they arrived to extend their invitation. They left a hastily scribbled note for him to read upon his return. We were by to ask you to go to the mountains with us. Sorry, you missed the fun. By the time Giulio and Candra arrived in the mountains, the weather was warm and the sky was blue. Amidst the bright light and picturesque setting, the couple's fears melted away. A wrong turn led them deeper into the forest on a road they'd never been down before.
令坎德拉惊讶的是，胡里奥承认他也对这次旅行感到莫名其妙的焦虑。为了安心，他们决定邀请胡里奥的一位朋友和他们一起露营，但当他们去发出邀请时，他不在家。他们留下了一张匆忙潦草的字条，让他回来时阅读。“我们来过，想请你和我们一起去山里。抱歉，你错过了乐趣。”当胡里奥和坎德拉到达山里时，天气温暖，天空湛蓝。在明亮的光线和风景如画的环境中，这对夫妇的恐惧烟消云散。一个错误的转弯把他们带到了森林更深处，走上了一条他们从未走过的路。
There was something about the road that gave Giulio the creeps. Eventually, they realized their mistake and turned around. That night, the pair slept in their car. Giulio spent the next day fishing, but he failed to catch anything. The couple moved on to a different location to see if Giulio would have better luck there. They followed the Clackamas River downstream, stopping periodically to cast a line. During one stop, they spoke to another fisherman who'd also been struggling. He'd heard that a truck full of fish had recently been moved to the Collawash River, a 12-mile tributary of the Clackamas River, and suggested that the couple
这条路有些地方让胡里奥感到毛骨悚然。最终，他们意识到自己错了，于是调转车头。那天晚上，两人睡在车里。胡里奥第二天花了一整天钓鱼，但什么也没钓到。这对夫妇搬到了另一个地点，看看胡里奥在那里是否会有更好的运气。他们沿着克拉克马斯河下游走，不时停下来抛竿。在一次停留期间，他们与另一位同样一直在挣扎的渔民交谈。他听说一卡车的鱼最近被转移到了科拉瓦什河（克拉克马斯河的一条12英里长的支流），并建议这对夫妇
check in with the park rangers to see if that was true. Giulio and Candra weren't sure what to do. They'd filled up their car with gas when they left, but now its tank was getting very low. They only had $20 left and needed to hang on to it in case of an emergency. After talking their predicament over, the couple decided to try one last location before giving up and returning home. The sun was setting when they reached the North Fork Dam. There, Giulio spotted a lone man observing the nearby fish ladder. Meeting Tom Brown was crystal clear in Candra's memory. She remembered how he lit up and flashed her a wide smile when she approached. It was sleazy as if he were undressing her with his eyes.
去咨询公园管理员看看是否属实。胡里奥和坎德拉不知道该怎么办。他们离开时把车加满了油，但现在油箱里的油已经很少了。他们只剩下20美元，需要留着以备不时之需。在讨论了他们的困境后，这对夫妇决定在放弃并回家之前尝试最后一个地点。当他们到达北岔大坝时，太阳正在落山。在那里，胡里奥发现了一个独自观察附近鱼梯的男人。坎德拉对遇见汤姆·布朗的记忆非常清晰。她记得当她走近时，他是如何亮起眼睛并对她露出灿烂笑容的。那很下流，就好像他在用眼睛脱她的衣服一样。
She never shook the uneasy feeling he gave her. That night, around the campfire, Tom retrieved a milk carton from his truck and showed it to Giulio and Candra. It contained a dead bird. I picked it off on the way here, Tom bragged. Candra was unimpressed. She didn't believe in shooting animals for sport. Not unless you have to for food, she told Tom. He told her not to worry and said he planned to eat the bird. On the walk the trio took later that night, Tom unsettled Candra further when he raised his rifle at several bear cubs playing in the distance. She turned away in disapproval,
她从未摆脱他带给她的不安感。那天晚上，在营火旁，汤姆从他的卡车里拿出一个牛奶盒，展示给胡里奥和坎德拉看。里面有一只死鸟。“我在来这里的路上把它打下来的，”汤姆吹嘘道。坎德拉对此印象不佳。她不相信为了运动而射杀动物。“除非你为了食物必须这样做，”她告诉汤姆。他让她别担心，并说他打算吃掉那只鸟。在三人当晚晚些时候的散步中，当汤姆向远处玩耍的几只小熊举起步枪时，他让坎德拉更加不安。她不赞同地转过身，
fearful his actions would attract the bear's mother and put them in danger. Tom flashed Candra yet another unnerving smile and lowered his weapon. Candra struggled to sleep that night. She didn't like Tom and the way he seemed to enjoy killing for its own sake. She expressed her concerns to Giulio and his friends. She didn't like her. She expressed her concerns to Giulio who regarded Tom as eccentric but harmless. Although he did tell Candra to button up her blouse to hide her bikini top. Candra's anxieties only increased the following day. She noticed how Tom loosely carried his rifle while keeping its barrel pointed at Giulio. Then he made a disturbing joke about her beloved
担心他的行为会引来母熊并使他们陷入危险。汤姆又对坎德拉露出了一个令人不安的微笑，放下了武器。坎德拉那天晚上很难入睡。她不喜欢汤姆，也不喜欢他似乎为了杀戮而杀戮的样子。她向胡里奥和他的朋友表达了她的担忧。她不喜欢他。她向胡里奥表达了她的担忧，胡里奥认为汤姆古怪但无害。尽管他确实告诉坎德拉扣上衬衫以遮住她的比基尼上衣。坎德拉的焦虑在第二天加剧了。她注意到汤姆是如何松散地携带步枪，同时让枪口指向胡里奥的。然后他开了一个关于她心爱的
dog. There are only two things wrong with Rusty, Tom said as he padded the collie. He's alive and walking. Despite remembering all of this lead up to Giulio's death, Candra realized that she couldn't actually recall the exact moment he was killed. She genuinely believed she had witnessed the shooting as she told detectives but she couldn't picture it in her mind. All that Candra could remember was the sound of a loud rifle blast then the sight of Giulio's body covered in blood. She tried to recall more but her mind was blank. Over the course of a few days another picture arose from Candra's subconscious. She could clearly see Tom Brown's face plastered with a wide smile.
狗的令人不安的玩笑。“拉斯蒂只有两点不好，”汤姆一边拍着牧羊犬一边说。“它还活着，还在走路。”尽管记得所有这些导致胡里奥死亡的铺垫，坎德拉意识到她实际上无法回忆起他被杀的确切时刻。她真诚地相信她目睹了枪击事件，正如她告诉侦探的那样，但她无法在脑海中想象出来。坎德拉唯一能记得的就是一声响亮的步枪声，然后是胡里奥尸体上沾满鲜血的景象。她试图回忆更多，但大脑一片空白。在几天的时间里，坎德拉的潜意识里浮现出另一幅画面。她能清楚地看到汤姆·布朗脸上挂着灿烂的笑容。
It wasn't until Candra returned to the apartment she and Giulio shared that something was unlocked within her. After begging her parents not to hate her and being reassured that they never could, Candra made a confession. She didn't know if Giulio's death was an accident or not because she hadn't actually seen it for herself. In shock her mother Lola replied, My God Candra, don't you realize that man murdered your husband? 6 days after Candra Torres and Tom Brown had emerged from the wilderness, Candra paid another visit to the county sheriff's office. This time she was accompanied by her parents.
直到坎德拉回到她和胡里奥合住的公寓，她内心深处的东西才被解锁。在恳求父母不要恨她并得到他们永远不会恨她的保证后，坎德拉坦白了。她不知道胡里奥的死是否是意外，因为她并没有亲眼看到。她的母亲萝拉震惊地回答：“天哪，坎德拉，你难道没意识到那个男人谋杀了你的丈夫吗？”在坎德拉·托雷斯和汤姆·布朗从荒野中出来6天后，坎德拉再次拜访了县治安官办公室。这一次，她的父母陪同她。
I want to tell you what really happened, Candra said. It wasn't an accident. On the morning of Saturday July 24, Candra gave Giulio a quick kiss before he left the campsite to go hunting with Tom Brown. Candra stayed put with Rusty who was resting in the sun. A sense of foreboding washed over her. The air was extremely still and quiet. Suddenly Candra was startled by the unmistakable sound of a gunshot ringing through the forest. For a split second Candra was overcome with the impulse to run into the woods with Rusty, but then she told herself to stop being silly. She had no way to navigate the forest and would only end up getting lost which would worry Giulio. There was no need to run. Giulio and Tom
“我想告诉你们真正发生了什么，”坎德拉说。“那不是意外。”7月24日星期六早上，坎德拉给了胡里奥一个快速的吻，然后他离开营地去和汤姆·布朗打猎。坎德拉和拉斯蒂留在原地，拉斯蒂正在阳光下休息。一种不祥的预感笼罩着她。空气异常平静和安静。突然，坎德拉被森林中响起的清晰枪声惊醒。有一瞬间，坎德拉被冲动所淹没，想带着拉斯蒂跑进树林，但随后她告诉自己不要再傻了。她无法在森林中导航，只会最终迷路，这会让胡里奥担心。没有必要逃跑。胡里奥和汤姆
must have found a deer. Candra remained where she was and waited for their return. A little while later she saw Tom walking towards the campsite. There was no sign of Giulio. As reported in the book Empty Promises, Tom called out to Candra. We got us a deer. He added that Giulio was still in the clearing, cleaning the carcass. Candra was immediately suspicious. It made no sense to her that Giulio would remain behind with the deer as he wasn't a hunter and wouldn't know how to gut an animal. Gripped with a fear that had been bubbling since she first met Tom Brown, Candra got up and ran towards the clearing. Another gunshot rang out.
一定找到了一只鹿。坎德拉留在原地等待他们回来。过了一会儿，她看到汤姆朝营地走来。没有胡里奥的踪影。正如《空洞的承诺》一书中所报道的那样，汤姆向坎德拉喊道：“我们打到了一只鹿。”他补充说胡里奥还在空地上清理尸体。坎德拉立刻产生了怀疑。胡里奥会留在鹿身边对她来说毫无意义，因为他不是猎人，也不知道如何给动物开膛破肚。被自她第一次见到汤姆·布朗以来就一直涌动的恐惧所笼罩，坎德拉起身跑向空地。又一声枪响。
Candra stopped and turned around. Rusty, who had been beside her a moment ago, had fallen on the ground. His legs jerked and his head was stained with blood. Tom stood a little distance behind holding a smoldering rifle. He then pointed it at Candra. You shot my dog, she cried. A broad grin appeared on Tom's face as he replied. Yeah, I know. I shot your husband too. At that moment, Candra Torres was certain she was going to die. Barely able to comprehend the enormity of the situation she was in, Candra begged Tom not to hurt her. Although he had been aiming his rifle at her, Tom didn't fire it.
坎德拉停下脚步，转过身。刚才还在她身边的拉斯蒂倒在了地上。它的腿抽搐着，头上沾满了鲜血。汤姆站在不远处，手里拿着一支冒烟的步枪。然后他用枪指着坎德拉。“你射杀了我的狗，”她哭喊道。汤姆脸上露出了灿烂的笑容，回答道：“是的，我知道。我也射杀了你的丈夫。”那一刻，坎德拉·托雷斯确信自己要死了。几乎无法理解她所处局势的严重性，坎德拉恳求汤姆不要伤害她。虽然他一直用步枪瞄准她，但汤姆没有开枪。
Instead, he forced Candra to drag Rusty's corpse off the trail and cover it with foliage. As she moved Rusty's body, Candra noticed that his paws were still twitching. Thinking he might be merely injured and able to be saved, Candra asked Tom to let her look after him. Tom refused. Those are his reflexes, he told Candra. I never have to shoot anything more than once. I don't like to see anything suffer. Once Candra covered Rusty's body, Tom bound her wrists and took her to the clearing where he had shot Julio.
相反，他强迫坎德拉把拉斯蒂的尸体拖离小径，并用树叶覆盖它。当她移动拉斯蒂的尸体时，坎德拉注意到它的爪子还在抽搐。以为它可能只是受伤了，还有救，坎德拉请求汤姆让她照顾它。汤姆拒绝了。“那是它的反射，”他告诉坎德拉。“我从来不需要射击任何东西超过一次。我不喜欢看到任何东西受苦。”一旦坎德拉覆盖了拉斯蒂的尸体，汤姆就绑住了她的手腕，把她带到了他射杀胡里奥的空地。
He warned her not to look at Julio's body as it would distress her and left her standing nearby while he retrieved a watch that Julio had been wearing. When Tom returned, he said to Candra, You're not allowed to cry. I'm going to tell you a story. His name wasn't really Tom, he told her. It was Kent. And he wasn't a logger. He was a hit man for an organized crime group. He'd murdered five or six people and was wanted across several different states. But now, Tom was on the run from the mobsters he'd worked for because he had killed, quote,
他警告她不要看胡里奥的尸体，因为这会让她心烦意乱，并让她站在附近，而他则去取胡里奥戴的一块手表。当汤姆回来时，他对坎德拉说：“你不准哭。我要给你讲个故事。”他告诉她，他的名字其实不叫汤姆。是肯特（Kent）。而且他也不是伐木工。他是一个有组织犯罪集团的杀手。他谋杀了五六个人，在几个不同的州被通缉。但现在，汤姆正在躲避他曾为其工作的黑帮，因为他杀了，引用，
One man too many. The reason he shot Julio was because he wanted a female companion and Candra looked strong enough to live off the land with him. After he finished explaining all of this, he said, Now you can cry. Candra wept uncontrollably before telling Tom that she had no idea how to live off the land. Tom just smiled and tried to hug her instead. After a little while, Tom made Candra pack up some belongings so they could begin hiking
“多了一个人。”他射杀胡里奥的原因是他想要一个女性伴侣，而坎德拉看起来足够强壮，可以和他一起在野外生存。在他解释完这一切后，他说：“现在你可以哭了。”坎德拉无法控制地哭泣，然后告诉汤姆她根本不知道如何靠土地生存。汤姆只是笑了笑，试图拥抱她。过了一会儿，汤姆让坎德拉收拾好一些物品，这样他们就可以开始徒步旅行
through the forest, claiming that the criminals he'd worked for were after them, he ordered her to change into a pair of army pants as camouflage. Tom said that if the mobsters managed to find them, Candra should run in the opposite direction as him for survival. The people pursuing him wouldn't harm her if they separated. They hiked for four hours. Tom insisted that Candra only step on rocks and stones to avoid leading footprints. If an aircraft flew overhead, she had to duck. As they walked, Tom occasionally discarded items by tossing them into the brush. Candra suspected he was trying to throw people off their path.
穿过森林，声称他曾为其工作的罪犯正在追捕他们，他命令她换上一条军裤作为伪装。汤姆说，如果黑帮设法找到他们，坎德拉应该朝与他相反的方向跑以求生存。如果他们分开，追捕他的人就不会伤害她。他们徒步走了四个小时。汤姆坚持要求坎德拉只踩在岩石和石头上，以避免留下脚印。如果有飞机从头顶飞过，她必须蹲下。当他们行走时，汤姆偶尔会通过把物品扔进灌木丛来丢弃它们。坎德拉怀疑他是在试图把人们引离他们的路径。
They eventually stopped by the river. While Candra went into the water to wash up, Tom lay on a sleeping bag. Then he demanded she join him and threatened her with a knife before raping her as she cried. After hiking throughout the rest of the day, they set up camp. Tom constantly told Candra disturbing things. He said he could have killed Julio with his bare hands if he wanted, but he chose to shoot him instead because it was quick and painless. He also revealed that he'd initially planned to murder Julio the previous evening, but decided to let the couple have one final night together out of kindness. Candra asked why he hadn't just left Julio tied up somewhere before abducting her.
他们最终在河边停了下来。当坎德拉下水清洗时，汤姆躺在睡袋上。然后他要求她加入他，并用刀威胁她，在她哭泣时强奸了她。在徒步走完剩下的一天后，他们扎营了。汤姆不断地告诉坎德拉令人不安的事情。他说如果他愿意，他可以用赤手空拳杀死胡里奥，但他选择射杀他，因为这既快速又无痛。他还透露，他最初计划在前一天晚上谋杀胡里奥，但出于仁慈，决定让这对夫妇最后再过一个晚上。坎德拉问他为什么不把胡里奥绑在某个地方再绑架她。
That would have been mean, Tom replied. Likewise, he said he had killed Rusty as an act of mercy because the dog wouldn't have been able to survive their journey. Tom told Candra stories about his violent past and the many murders he had committed. He was a big fan of a Dolph Hitler and said he hated his family. When he wasn't ranting, Tom would rape Candra. She was struck by how nasty looking his eyes were. Candra was led further into the woods. Whenever Tom paused to take a break, Candra pulled out the Bible her friend had encouraged her to pack and read aloud from it. Taking note of her faith, Tom told Candra that he too had been a Christian once,
“那太刻薄了，”汤姆回答。同样，他说他杀死拉斯蒂是一种仁慈的行为，因为这只狗无法在他们的旅程中幸存下来。汤姆给坎德拉讲了他暴力过去和许多谋杀案的故事。他是多尔夫·希特勒（Dolph Hitler）的忠实粉丝，并说他恨他的家人。当他不咆哮时，汤姆就会强奸坎德拉。她被他那双看起来很邪恶的眼睛所震撼。坎德拉被带进树林更深处。每当汤姆停下来休息时，坎德拉就会拿出她朋友鼓励她带上的圣经，大声朗读。注意到她的信仰，汤姆告诉坎德拉，他曾经也是一个基督徒，
but he knew that God had given up on him. Candra replied that God didn't give up on anybody. As time went on, the pair continued to talk. They had long conversations about a wide range of topics from films and books to deeper subjects such as the nature of humanity. At one point, Tom told Candra how the human mind held multiple doors that one could open and close at will. When he needed to kill a person, he simply opened a door in his brain that allowed that. Candra found herself gradually forgetting about the terrible things Tom had done, but his mood could change in an instant. He would go from being caring and considerate to angry without warning. On Monday, July 26, two days after the murder of Julio,
但他知道上帝已经放弃了他。坎德拉回答说，上帝不会放弃任何人。随着时间的推移，两人继续交谈。他们就广泛的话题进行了长时间的对话，从电影和书籍到更深层次的主题，如人性的本质。有一次，汤姆告诉坎德拉人类的思想如何拥有多扇门，人们可以随意打开和关闭。当他需要杀人时，他只是打开大脑中允许这样做的一扇门。坎德拉发现自己逐渐忘记了汤姆所做的可怕事情，但他的情绪可能会瞬间改变。他会毫无预兆地从关心和体贴变得愤怒。7月26日星期一，胡里奥被谋杀两天后，
Tom woke up with a bad cough and told Candra that he thought he had pneumonia. He asked her for some paper so he could write letters to friends, explaining that he would probably be dead soon. At the thought of being left lost in the forest all alone, Candra began to cry. And for the first time, so did Tom. Then he told Candra something. He hadn't actually meant to kill Julio, but he was worried no one would believe him. As described by Candra in the Forensic Files episode Head Games, Tom said,
汤姆醒来时咳嗽得很厉害，告诉坎德拉他认为自己得了肺炎。他向她要了一些纸，以便写信给朋友，解释说他可能很快就会死。一想到被独自留在森林里迷路，坎德拉就开始哭泣。这是第一次，汤姆也哭了。然后他告诉坎德拉一件事。他其实并不是故意要杀胡里奥，但他担心没有人会相信他。正如坎德拉在《法医档案》剧集《头脑游戏》（Head Games）中所描述的那样，汤姆说，
I didn't kill your husband on purpose. It was an accident. The reason that I brought you up here is because I'm afraid to go back to prison. Candra asked Tom if he was sure it was an accident. He told her over and over that he was. Slowly, Candra began to believe him. Armed with this new information, she made a promise. If you're sure, I'll go to the police with you and tell them I saw it, Candra said. Her words made Tom smile. Tom Brown agreed to take Candra Torres back to the campsite where Julio and Rusty's bodies still
“我不是故意杀你丈夫的。那是一场意外。我把你带到这里的原因是因为我害怕回到监狱。”坎德拉问汤姆他是否确定那是意外。他一遍又一遍地告诉她是的。慢慢地，坎德拉开始相信他。带着这个新信息，她做出了一个承诺。“如果你确定，我会和你一起去警察局，告诉他们我看到了，”坎德拉说。她的话让汤姆笑了。汤姆·布朗同意带坎德拉·托雷斯回到胡里奥和拉斯蒂的尸体仍然
lay. Then he would head back into the forest while Candra could make her way back home. Through repeated conversations, Candra managed to convince Tom to join her in reporting the accident to authorities. The thought of leaving an ill man alone in the woods made her uneasy. When she promised to vouch for him with law enforcement, he agreed to join her. They made it back to the area where they'd left their vehicles and got into Tom's truck. By the time they arrived at his lawyer's office the following morning, Candra had heard Tom describe how the rifle had misfired so many times that she truly believed she had seen it with her own eyes. Tom also insisted that he only shot Rusty in self-defense after the dog attacked him.
躺着的地方。然后他会回到森林里，而坎德拉可以自己回家。通过反复的交谈，坎德拉设法说服汤姆和她一起向当局报告这起事故。想到把一个生病的男人独自留在树林里让她感到不安。当她承诺在执法部门面前为他作证时，他同意加入她。他们回到了他们留下车辆的地方，上了汤姆的卡车。第二天早上当他们到达他律师的办公室时，坎德拉已经听汤姆描述了步枪是如何走火的，次数多到她真的相信自己亲眼目睹了这一切。汤姆还坚持说他只是在狗攻击他后出于自卫才射杀了拉斯蒂。
Candra was convinced of this too. Detectives were stunned as they listened to Candra relate this entirely new version of events. They had believed the story that she and Tom Brown had originally told them and considered the case nothing more than an unfortunate accident. After hearing Candra's amended account, they asked her to sit a polygraph test. Tom had already taken one after being interviewed twice and he had passed with no problems at all. Candra agreed to their request, but to her dismay, she failed the exam. Despite this, investigators were intrigued by Candra's new story. The truth was that Tom, whose full name was Thomas Leslie Brown, had an extensive criminal
坎德拉也对此深信不疑。侦探们在听坎德拉讲述这个全新的事件版本时惊呆了。他们相信了她和汤姆·布朗最初告诉他们的故事，并认为这起案件不过是一场不幸的意外。在听完坎德拉修改后的陈述后，他们要求她参加测谎仪测试。汤姆在被采访两次后已经参加过一次，并且毫无问题地通过了。坎德拉同意了他们的请求，但令她沮丧的是，她没能通过考试。尽管如此，调查人员对坎德拉的新故事很感兴趣。事实是，汤姆，全名托马斯·莱斯利·布朗（Thomas Leslie Brown），有着广泛的犯罪记录。
history that included a number of violent crimes. At the age of 16, he acquired a rifle and ammunition from a friend then went out looking for people to rob. He and another teenager drove towards the city of Canby and spotted a woman also driving on the same road. They ran her off the bitum then raced up to her car while wielding the gun and demanding money. The woman locked her vehicle's doors so Brown fired the rifle twice. Believing he'd hit the woman, he and his friends ran into a nearby forest. When they emerged a little while later, the woman's car was still parked by the side of the road but there was no sign of her. She had fled unscathed from the vehicle. Tom and his friend got back in their
他有着包括多项暴力犯罪在内的前科。16岁时，他从朋友那里弄到了一支步枪和弹药，然后出去寻找抢劫目标。他和另一名少年开车前往坎比市，发现一名女子也在同一条路上开车。他们将她的车逼出路面，然后挥舞着枪冲向她的车，索要钱财。那名女子锁上了车门，于是布朗开了两枪。他以为自己打中了那名女子，便和朋友跑进了附近的森林。过了一会儿，当他们出来时，那名女子的车仍停在路边，但不见她的踪影。她已安然无恙地逃离了车辆。汤姆和他的朋友回到了他们的
car and sped away in the hopes of finding another victim. Suddenly, a police car appeared in front of them, its lights flashing. Realizing it was coming for them, the two teenagers veered towards a turn off and hit a truck. Their car flipped over. Tom fired out a window at the pursuing police officer but missed. He crawled from the car and fled on foot. Spotting a male passerby, he went up to him and demanded his car keys. The man said he had none so Tom tried his luck at a house instead. A teenage girl answered the door and when Tom threatened her, she ran across the street to a neighbor's property. Noticing the neighbor's pickup truck parked outside, Tom decided to steal it. He aimed his rifle at a young man standing in the window of the house
车上，加速逃离，希望能找到下一个受害者。突然，一辆警车闪着警灯出现在他们面前。意识到警察是冲着他们来的，两名少年转向一个路口，结果撞上了一辆卡车。他们的车翻了。汤姆从车窗向追赶的警察开枪，但没打中。他从车里爬出来，徒步逃跑。看到一名男性路人，他走上前去索要车钥匙。那人说他没有车，于是汤姆转而尝试去一户人家碰碰运气。一名十几岁的女孩开了门，当汤姆威胁她时，她跑过马路去了邻居家。注意到邻居的皮卡车停在外面，汤姆决定偷走它。他把步枪对准了站在窗边的年轻男子
and fired. This time, his shot hit its mark. The young man was wounded in the stomach. Tom got into the pickup truck but immediately discovered there wasn't enough room in its cab for him to aim his weapon. He hopped out again just as Sheriff's deputies arrived on the scene. When officers later interviewed Tom and asked if he was responsible for shooting the young man, Tom replied, Yeah, I wanted his car and I was willing to kill to get it. Luckily, his victim survived. Tom Brown was sent to a reform school but picked up his criminal career again upon release. For a while, he mostly engaged in petty crimes before developing an interest in a woman who had
并开了枪。这一次，他击中了目标。那名年轻男子的腹部受了伤。汤姆上了皮卡车，但立刻发现驾驶室里没有足够的空间让他瞄准武器。就在治安官副手赶到现场时，他又跳了出来。当警察后来审问汤姆并询问他是否应对枪击那名年轻男子负责时，汤姆回答说：“是的，我想要他的车，为了得到它，我愿意杀人。”幸运的是，他的受害者活了下来。汤姆·布朗被送进了感化学校，但获释后又重操旧业。有一段时间，他主要从事轻微犯罪，后来对一名女子产生了兴趣，该女子有
two young children. After a short period, she ended their relationship. Furious at this, Tom abducted the woman and her children, then took them up to the mountains. He held them hostage overnight before releasing them. The woman declined to press charges out of fear that Tom would come after her. He openly spoke of the incident with police, stating, I was going to have her one way or another. I would have burned down her house, used a gun, whatever it took, so no one else would have her either. After this, Tom relocated to the Midwestern state of Nebraska and started working on a farm. His employer lent Tom his red GMC pickup truck. One day, Tom told his boss he planned to drive
两个年幼的孩子。过了一段时间，她结束了他们的关系。汤姆对此大发雷霆，绑架了这名女子和她的孩子，并将他们带到了山上。他将他们扣为人质过了一夜，然后才释放了他们。由于担心汤姆会找她报复，这名女子拒绝提出指控。他公开向警方谈论了这件事，声称：“我无论如何都要得到她。我会烧掉她的房子，用枪，不惜一切代价，这样别人也别想得到她。”此后，汤姆搬到了中西部的内布拉斯加州，开始在农场工作。他的雇主把他的红色GMC皮卡车借给了汤姆。一天，汤姆告诉老板他打算开车
the truck into town. He had two of his employer's rifles with him at the time. An entire day went by with no sign of Tom or the truck. When Tom's employer realized he'd been robbed, he filed a stolen vehicle report with the police. There was a warrant out for Tom's arrest in Nebraska, but law enforcement there never caught sight of him again. It turned out that he had driven the stolen pickup all the way back to Oregon. Tom's history of violence made investigators inclined to believe Candra Torres' second account of events, despite her failing her polygraph test. Although polygraphs are used in some jurisdictions as an interrogative tool and are sometimes referred
去镇上。当时他带着雇主的步枪。整整一天过去了，汤姆和卡车都没有踪影。当汤姆的雇主意识到自己被抢劫后，他向警方报了车辆被盗案。内布拉斯加州对汤姆发出了逮捕令，但那里的执法部门再也没有见过他。事实证明，他已经把偷来的皮卡车一路开回了俄勒冈州。汤姆的暴力史使调查人员倾向于相信桑德拉·托雷斯对事件的第二次陈述，尽管她没能通过测谎仪测试。虽然测谎仪在某些司法管辖区被用作审讯工具，有时被称为
to as lie detectors, they cannot detect lies. They measure physiological responses to different questions, and an individual's results will depend on many factors. Countermeasures such as controlled breathing and thought exercises can help someone pass a polygraph. Likewise, a person who is nervous and emotional may provide responses that the examiner perceives as dishonest. As Candra Torres' mother later told forensic files, polygraphs do not measure truth or lie, what they measure is emotion. And if you were a 16-year-old girl that had been raped, marched up in the mountain, you're talking about your husband that you loved that was shot by this murderer. Would you be emotional? I think so.
测谎仪，但它们并不能检测谎言。它们测量的是对不同问题的生理反应，个人的结果将取决于许多因素。受控呼吸和思维练习等反制措施可以帮助某人通过测谎。同样，一个紧张和情绪化的人可能会提供检查员认为不诚实的反应。正如桑德拉·托雷斯的母亲后来告诉《法医档案》的那样，测谎仪测量的不是真相或谎言，它们测量的是情绪。如果你是一个16岁的女孩，被强奸，被带到山上，你谈论的是你深爱的丈夫被这个杀人犯枪杀。你会情绪激动吗？我想会的。
However, investigators knew that they needed more information if they were to proceed with a murder charge. They referred Candra to a forensic psychiatrist in the hopes he might be able to shed further light on what had happened. Dr. Joseph Treleven worked at Oregon State Hospital as head of the psychiatric security unit. He spent several hours interviewing Candra Torres about her ordeal. Dr. Treleven sought to determine why Candra had vehemently defended and supported her rapist and kidnapper, who she knew deep down had gunned down her husband and dog. He noted that Candra's early defense of her captor reminded him of stories he had read about American POWs during the Korean War. In situations where these hostages were isolated, tortured,
然而，调查人员知道，如果他们要以谋杀罪起诉，就需要更多的信息。他们将桑德拉转介给了一位法医精神病学家，希望他能进一步阐明发生了什么。约瑟夫·特雷文医生在俄勒冈州立医院担任精神病安全部门的负责人。他花了几个小时采访桑德拉·托雷斯，了解她的遭遇。特雷文医生试图确定为什么桑德拉会极力维护和支持她的强奸犯和绑架者，而她内心深处知道正是此人枪杀了她的丈夫和狗。他指出，桑德拉对绑架者早期的辩护让他想起了他读过的关于朝鲜战争期间美国战俘的故事。在这些俘虏被孤立、折磨的情况下，
and lived in fear of being killed, they sometimes began to identify with their captor's point of view. Occasionally, they even went so far as to testify against the United States. Those who studied this phenomenon dubbed it brainwashing. In 1973, three years before Julio and Candra Torres encountered Tom Brown, it became known as Stockholm Syndrome, after a bank robbery in Sweden where hostages subsequently defended their captors. The term made headlines in the U.S. at the start of 1976, when Eris Paddy Hearst was trialled for her role in a bank robbery. Hearst had been abducted in 1974 by a left-wing organization and was held hostage by them for
并且生活在被杀的恐惧中，他们有时开始认同绑架者的观点。有时，他们甚至走得更远，作证反对美国。研究这种现象的人称之为洗脑。1973年，在胡里奥和桑德拉·托雷斯遇到汤姆·布朗的三年前，它被称为斯德哥尔摩综合征，源于瑞典发生的一起银行抢劫案，人质随后为绑架者辩护。这个词在1976年初登上了美国头条，当时埃里斯·帕蒂·赫斯特因其在银行抢劫案中的角色而受审。赫斯特于1974年被一个左翼组织绑架，并被他们扣为人质长达
19 months. While prosecutors claimed Hearst had willingly aligned herself with her captors and agreed to participate in the robbery, her lawyer insisted she had been brainwashed. Some experts in psychology say Stockholm Syndrome occurs when a victim suffers a traumatic shock at the hands of a captor, who then isolates them, indoctrinates them, and promises an eventual reward. In Candra Torres's case, the shooting of Julio and Rusty, along with being repeatedly raped, qualified as traumatic shocks, she was then isolated and indoctrinated by Tom Brown, who repeatedly told her Julio's shooting was an accident. Her reward was being released by Tom if she went along with his story. Stockholm Syndrome is not an official psychiatric disorder
19个月。虽然检察官声称赫斯特自愿与绑架者结盟并同意参与抢劫，但她的律师坚称她被洗脑了。一些心理学专家表示，当受害者在绑架者手中遭受创伤性休克，然后被孤立、灌输并被承诺最终获得奖励时，就会出现斯德哥尔摩综合征。在桑德拉·托雷斯的案例中，胡里奥和拉斯特被枪杀，加上被反复强奸，构成了创伤性休克，她随后被汤姆·布朗孤立和灌输，汤姆反复告诉她胡里奥的枪击是一场意外。她的奖励是如果她顺从他的故事，就会被汤姆释放。斯德哥尔摩综合征不是一种官方的精神疾病
and does not appear in the DSM-5, a diagnostic manual published by the American Psychiatric Association. Some experts and commentators have criticized the theory of Stockholm Syndrome, pointing out that psychiatrists and psychologists have been unable to reach a consensus on it. The FBI has described the condition as extremely rare. The very case that gave the phenomenon its name is contentious, as police actions in the Stockholm Bank robbery case arguably placed the hostages at greater risk. This provides another explanation for why those hostages may have refused to testify against their captors. Regardless of debate about the condition, Dr. Treleven and investigators came to the conclusion
并且没有出现在美国精神医学学会出版的诊断手册《精神疾病诊断与统计手册》(DSM-5)中。一些专家和评论员批评了斯德哥尔摩综合征的理论，指出精神病学家和心理学家无法就此达成共识。联邦调查局将这种情况描述为极其罕见。赋予这种现象名称的案例本身就存在争议，因为斯德哥尔摩银行抢劫案中的警察行动可以说使人质处于更大的风险之中。这为这些人质为何可能拒绝作证反对绑架者提供了另一种解释。无论关于这种情况的争论如何，特雷文医生和调查人员得出的结论是
that Candra Torres had allied herself with her abductor as a way to survive. For Candra, the thought that her husband and dog had been killed just because a stranger wanted her to himself was deeply distressing. She wanted to believe it had all been a tragic accident, because then she wouldn't feel guilty about what happened. Talking to producers of forensic files, Candra said, I had nobody with me but a murderer. Do I really want to believe he is a murderer, because believing that is terrifying? Do I really want to think that my husband died so that someone could rape me and kidnap me? For me, denial was the best way to survive.
桑德拉·托雷斯与绑架者结盟是为了生存。对桑德拉来说，她的丈夫和狗仅仅因为一个陌生人想独占她而被杀，这种想法让她深感痛苦。她想相信这一切只是一场悲剧性的意外，因为那样她就不会对发生的事情感到内疚。在与《法医档案》的制片人交谈时，桑德拉说：“除了一个杀人犯，我身边没有人。我真的想相信他是一个杀人犯吗？因为相信这一点太可怕了。我真的想认为我的丈夫死是为了让某人强奸我并绑架我吗？对我来说，否认是生存的最佳方式。”
Although detectives believed Candra's accusations against Tom Brown, they had no way of proving them. Candra's conflicting statements and failed polygraph exam could be used by a defense to undermine her credibility and label her an unreliable witness. Plus, she hadn't seen Tom shoot Giulio, she had only heard it. They needed physical evidence to prove there had been a murder. While Candra said Tom shot Rusty from behind, Tom had claimed he shot the dog as the animal ran towards him. If this was true, the bullet would have entered Rusty's head from the front. Sheriff's deputies had taken photographs of Rusty's body at the campsite, but didn't arrange an autopsy for the dog. With Rusty long since buried in a mass grave,
虽然侦探们相信桑德拉对汤姆·布朗的指控，但他们无法证明。桑德拉相互矛盾的陈述和未通过的测谎考试可能会被辩方用来削弱她的可信度，并将她贴上不可靠证人的标签。此外，她并没有亲眼看到汤姆枪杀胡里奥，她只是听到了。他们需要物证来证明发生了谋杀案。虽然桑德拉说汤姆从背后枪杀了拉斯特，但汤姆声称他在动物跑向他时开枪打死了它。如果这是真的，子弹会从正面进入拉斯特的头部。治安官副手在营地拍摄了拉斯特尸体的照片，但没有安排对这只狗进行尸检。由于拉斯特早已被埋在乱葬岗中，
they had no way of checking which version was true. However, they did have some forensics to go on in Giulio's case. Experts had found no gunpowder residue on Giulio's face where the bullet had entered, which indicated that he hadn't been shot at a very close range. In order to find out the minimum distance he could have been shot from, ballistics experts did some tests with Tom Brown's rifle. When fired six inches from its target, it left a visible gunpowder pattern. The experts tried firing it at gradually increasing distances and discovered that it wasn't until the rifle was fired at least 36 inches from its target that the target
他们无法核实哪个版本是真实的。然而，他们在胡里奥的案件中确实有一些法医证据。专家们在胡里奥头部中弹的脸上没有发现火药残留，这表明他不是在极近距离被枪杀的。为了找出他被枪杀的最小距离，弹道专家用汤姆·布朗的步枪进行了一些测试。当在距离目标6英寸处开火时，它留下了可见的火药痕迹。专家们尝试在逐渐增加的距离上开火，发现直到步枪在距离目标至少36英寸处开火时，目标才
remained free from gunpowder. This meant Tom Brown had been a minimum of 3 feet away from Giulio when the rifle went off. This distance, combined with the almost horizontal entry and exit wound in Giulio's head and neck, meant Tom's story of an accidental misfire while the gun was being passed between them didn't hold up. Detectives couldn't arrest Tom Brown as he had gone off the grid after their last interview. Prosecutors instead took the case to a grand jury to determine whether the death of Giulio Torres was a murder or an accident. In December 1976, almost five months after Giulio was killed, the grand jury reached a decision. Giulio had been murdered. An indictment was handed down, charging Tom Brown with murder as well as car theft and forgery.
保持没有火药残留。这意味着汤姆·布朗在步枪走火时距离胡里奥至少有3英尺远。这个距离，加上胡里奥头部和颈部几乎水平的入口和出口伤口，意味着汤姆关于在枪支传递过程中意外走火的故事站不住脚。侦探们无法逮捕汤姆·布朗，因为他在上次采访后就失踪了。检察官转而将此案提交给大陪审团，以确定胡里奥·托雷斯的死亡是谋杀还是意外。1976年12月，在胡里奥被杀近五个月后，大陪审团做出了决定。胡里奥是被谋杀的。起诉书下达，指控汤姆·布朗犯有谋杀罪以及汽车盗窃罪和伪造罪。
Months went by. Then one day, Sheriff's deputies were stunned to see Tom walk into their offices. He looked cool, calm and collected as he approached the front desk and explained that he'd heard there was a warrant out for his arrest. Tom said he was keen to get it all straightened out. The Sheriff's office wasted no time in arresting Tom Brown and charging him with murder. Then he was transferred to county jail to await trial. Investigators needed a definitive statement from Candra Torres that they could take to court. After encouragement from a criminal investigator, Candra began writing down her memories of her ordeal as they came to mind. When she was finally finished, she had written 18 pages detailing everything that had happened.
几个月过去了。一天，治安官副手惊讶地看到汤姆走进他们的办公室。他看起来冷静、沉着、镇定，走到前台解释说他听说有针对他的逮捕令。汤姆说他很想把这一切理清楚。治安官办公室毫不耽搁地逮捕了汤姆·布朗，并指控他谋杀。随后他被转移到县监狱等待审判。调查人员需要桑德拉·托雷斯的一份明确声明，以便他们可以带到法庭。在刑事调查员的鼓励下，桑德拉开始写下她对遭遇的记忆。当她最终完成时，她写了18页，详细记录了发生的一切。
Meanwhile, Tom Brown was pleased to discover that his county jail cellmate was a man who would previously known as an adolescent at reform school. This individual was given the pseudonym Wendell Stokeberry by true crime author Ian Ruhl in her book Empty Promises. Like Tom, Wendell had an extensive criminal background and Tom felt comfortable confiding in him. He began discussing his upcoming trial, assuring Wendell, quote, I'm going to beat it. Tom openly told Wendell how he had deliberately shot Giulio in the face, claiming that he had been hired to murder him. Then he bragged about how he had convinced Candra Torres to go along with his story about an accidental shooting and said she
与此同时，汤姆·布朗很高兴地发现他的县监狱牢友是一个他以前在感化学校认识的少年。这个人在真实犯罪作家伊恩·鲁尔的书《空洞的承诺》中被赋予了温德尔·斯托克伯里的化名。像汤姆一样，温德尔有着广泛的犯罪背景，汤姆觉得可以放心地向他吐露心声。他开始讨论即将到来的审判，向温德尔保证说：“我会打赢这场官司。”汤姆公开告诉温德尔他是如何故意射击胡里奥的脸的，声称他是受雇谋杀他的。然后他吹嘘自己是如何说服桑德拉·托雷斯顺从他关于意外枪击的故事，并说她
wasn't emotionally strong enough to go through with testifying against him. A jury wouldn't find her convincing either, Tom said, because she looked older than her actual age and had a seductive demeanor. Plus, he had passed a polygraph test. He'd done that by simply choosing to believe in the lies he had invented. Tom said that when he was acquitted, he'd killed the case's prosecutors, then go after Candra. On the off chance that he was convicted, his sentence would probably only be around seven years, and he could still get his revenge against Candra upon release. Wendell reported everything Tom told him to prosecutors. They believed Wendell because there were details in his story that no one knew except those with
在情感上不够坚强，无法坚持作证指控他。汤姆说，陪审团也不会觉得她有说服力，因为她看起来比实际年龄大，而且举止诱人。此外，他通过了测谎测试。他通过简单地选择相信他编造的谎言做到了这一点。汤姆说，当他被判无罪时，他会杀了案件的检察官，然后去追杀桑德拉。万一他被定罪，他的刑期可能只有七年左右，他出狱后仍然可以向桑德拉报仇。温德尔向检察官报告了汤姆告诉他的一切。他们相信温德尔，因为他的故事中有一些细节是除了那些
an intimate knowledge of the crimes. In exchange for an escape charge removed from his criminal record and a sentence in an out-of-state prison, Wendell agreed to testify against his old friend. Two days before Tom Brown's trial was set to begin, he managed to source enough money for bail and was released. Candra Torres was moved to a motel for her own protection and was kept under 24-hour police guard. The defendant was given the choice of a jury trial or trial by judge and opted for the latter. His former friend Wendell appeared as a witness, as did Dr. Joseph Treleven, who spoke at length about the phenomenon of Stockholm syndrome. Despite her continuing fear of the man who abducted her, Candra Torres managed to testify
对犯罪有深入了解的人之外无人知晓的。为了换取从犯罪记录中删除逃跑指控并在州外监狱服刑，温德尔同意出庭指控他的老朋友。在汤姆·布朗的审判开始前两天，他设法筹集了足够的保释金并获释。桑德拉·托雷斯被转移到一家汽车旅馆以保护她自己的安全，并由警察24小时守卫。被告可以选择陪审团审判或法官审判，他选择了后者。他以前的朋友温德尔作为证人出庭，约瑟夫·特雷文医生也出庭了，他详细谈到了斯德哥尔摩综合征现象。尽管仍然害怕绑架她的那个人，桑德拉·托雷斯还是设法作证
at length over one and a half days. Tom Brown also took the stand in his own defense. He tried to demonstrate how the alleged accident took place, showing how he'd handed over the rifle to Julio. But his demonstration fell flat when it became clear that this handoff was incompatible with the wound that Julio had received. It took the judge three days to reach a ruling. He found Tom Brown guilty and sentenced him to life in the Oregon State Penitentiary. Tom Brown has applied for parole a number of times over the ensuing decades, without success. As of early 2022, he remains incarcerated, but he is scheduled to be released in August 2023. He is currently 75 years old.
长达一天半的时间。汤姆·布朗也为自己的辩护出庭作证。他试图演示所谓的意外是如何发生的，展示他是如何把步枪交给胡里奥的。但当很明显这种交接与胡里奥受到的伤口不符时，他的演示就失败了。法官花了三天时间才做出裁决。他判决汤姆·布朗有罪，并判处他在俄勒冈州立监狱终身监禁。在随后的几十年里，汤姆·布朗多次申请假释，但都没有成功。截至2022年初，他仍被监禁，但他定于2023年8月获释。他目前75岁。
The case of Julio and Candra Torres was written about extensively by true crime author Ann Ruhl. She detailed the events of their camping trip and the investigation that followed in a chapter of her 2001 book, Empty Promises. Although Candra kept a low profile for many years after her ordeal, in 2020 she shared her story with fellow kidnapping survivor Elizabeth Smart, who was abducted from her Utah home in 2002 at the age of 14. The two women revisited the location where Candra was abducted for an episode of the television series Elizabeth Smart Finding Justice. It was the first time Candra had been back to Mount Hood National Forest since Julio's murder. She said the visit made her feel empowered.
胡里奥和桑德拉·托雷斯的案件被真实犯罪作家安·鲁尔广泛撰写。她在2001年的书《空洞的承诺》的一章中详细描述了他们的露营之旅和随后的调查。虽然桑德拉在遭遇后多年保持低调，但在2020年，她与同样是绑架幸存者的伊丽莎白·斯马特分享了她的故事，后者于2002年14岁时在犹他州的家中被绑架。这两名女性重访了桑德拉被绑架的地点，拍摄了电视连续剧《伊丽莎白·斯马特寻找正义》的一集。这是桑德拉自胡里奥被谋杀以来第一次回到胡德山国家森林。她说这次访问让她感到充满力量。
Candra Torres is grateful for the physical evidence that helped put her attacker and her husband's killer behind bars. As she told the television program Forensic Files in 2004, I thank God for forensics. I think that they solve a lot of crimes. The angle of the shot and the type of gun that was used and the powder burns were all proof that this did not happen the way that he said it did. So I was very thankful for that evidence. Candra eventually remarried, moved far away and started a family. She credits psychiatry with helping her recover and understand how her memories were able to be distorted and manipulated by Tom Brown. Candra has found comfort in knowing there is a logical
桑德拉·托雷斯感谢那些帮助将她的袭击者和她丈夫的杀手绳之以法的物证。正如她在2004年告诉电视节目《法医档案》的那样：“我感谢上帝赐予法医科学。我认为它们解决了很多犯罪。射击的角度、使用的枪支类型和火药烧伤都是证明这并没有像他说的那样发生的证据。所以我非常感谢那些证据。”桑德拉最终再婚，搬到了很远的地方并组建了家庭。她将自己的康复归功于精神病学，并理解了她的记忆是如何被汤姆·布朗扭曲和操纵的。桑德拉在知道有一个合乎逻辑的解释时感到安慰
explanation for her reaction to trauma and in having her name publicly cleared. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
对她创伤反应的解释，并让她的名字公开洗清。目前还没有关于这一集的评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。